hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
within diogenes Lair tastes life of
aristipus in book six of his lives of
the philosophers we find a discussion of
some of the other members of the
syrenaic school and perhaps one of the
most interesting of these besides the
founder aristipus is this guy hegesius
who is often read as being quite a
pessimist right now diogenes says that
the school of higasias adopted the same
ends the same goals the scopus literally
the things that you're aiming at
Pleasure and Pain so they're like the
other syrianics in that respect
but they're going to differ on some
other matters drawing different
conclusions than some of the other
serenaeics have done and so it's good to
start with the wise person what do they
think of the sofos or the fronimos the
person who really has it figured out the
sage sometimes we call them so you know
as we've talked about elsewhere the
sereneric sage is you know maybe not
quite such a lofty figure as the sage is
in some of the other schools of ancient
philosophy but they do have advantages
over other people so
one of the first things that we can
attend to is this interesting quip that
life is advantageous to the fool Lucy
teles literally so it's it's something
that's you know
useful something that's that's
profitable is another way of putting it
but to the whys and here it's uh
fronimos the person who you know has
practical wisdom it is something that is
indifferent a diaphoron right so it's
not saying that life is bad it's just
living and dying as they point out uh a
little bit earlier on life and death are
each desirable
in certain circumstances so you know if
your life really sucks then if you're a
sage then you'd be like I'm not getting
anything out of this it's much more
painful than pleasurable maybe I'll let
it go whereas the fool you know
presumably in this it's not that life
really is profitable to the fool the
fool thinks of life that way they are
unduly attached to life now another
thing that we learn about the sage
that's quite interesting is that they
are
self-interested in a rational way right
so they will act in all things they will
engage in actions or conduct praxe right
out of their own interests how to
hennika so hennika means on account of
and how to is you know one's own self so
they will be taking their own self and
what's good for them or bad bad for them
into account more than anybody else why
well because there's nobody else who
this person regards as equally deserving
oxyon Auto oxion oxios is a word that we
actually get Axiom from something that
is worth
considering right and so Auto in this
case is also themself and so
it's not to say that other people don't
matter at all but if you're a sage you
realize you're a sage and everybody else
is kind of you know falling short of
that and then there's another great line
here as well about the wise person
supposing him to reap the greatest
advantages from another right to
literally Harvest like fruit the
greatest things well they still would
not be equal and the word here again is
oxia but here it's antoxia there's no
comparison in return for what it is that
the sage brings to the table what it is
that they contribute so again not a
denial that other people can contribute
something but the sage is
better off and there's another thing
that we learn about the sage that I
think is really interesting here
so hegesius apparently did not consider
the sage to be better off than everybody
else in every single respect when it
comes to the ultimate you know goods and
bads of Life namely pleasures and pains
what we learn here is that the sage is
better off with respect to avoiding or
rejecting the things that are painful
evils right fuge and they are not better
off with respect to choosing
the good which is pleasure that's that's
quite interesting isn't it and this you
know fleeing or rejecting and pursuing
or choosing this is really a basic
category for ancient moral theory right
uh that is part of what ethics is all
about is is choosing and rejecting and
making those choices on the right basis
so this is a you know kind of a
different picture of what the wise
person's life is going to be if if the
serenaic idea in general is a bit of a
deflation or lowering of the idea of the
sage I would say that with higessius it
goes even a little bit lower as well
now the sage for hegesias and his school
is realizing what it is that other
people should be realizing as well but
are often deluded about and one of these
things is that there's no real gratitude
Harris in Greek right being thankful to
other people for having done things for
you there's no real friendship philia
right and there's no real beneficence
you ergasia literally like doing good to
other people are doing things that are
good for other people and why is that
the case well he tells us that the
hagasians think none of these things are
actually chosen for their own sake so
this this qualifies it a bit Yeah
there's things we call friendship
there's things we call gratitude there's
things we call beneficence there's
things that look like it but none of
these are chosen because they're the
good thing or the right thing to do but
because of a kind of usefulness
you know it could be interpreted in a
couple different ways it's interesting
because this is also a term that gets
used for like sayings but it could also
be like you know social expectations
but it it has to do with using right
um and so
these are the things that we use to get
by in the world but they don't have
value in and of themselves the way that
many other philosophers think that they
do now we get to another really
distinctive
um doctrine of the hegesian crnaics in
this notion that happiness eudaimonia
happiness in the full extent is actually
impossible it can't be produced or
realized now the other serenais before
this
an aristipus seemed to think that yeah
there is happiness eudaimonia but it's
not actually the goal of Life what is
the goal of life enjoying particular
Pleasures that compose happiness if you
try to aim at happiness directly you're
not going to realize that it's better to
pursue the pleasures that are in front
of you here's where hegesius you know
could be viewed as rather pessimistic so
happiness is impossible why
well because the body itself is infected
with all sorts of we could translate
this as passions or sufferings and this
is kind of an interesting phrase here
because uh what they're they're actually
saying is that these things are woven
into the body right it's sort of like
this is the nature of of human beings
you know so you know for some of us like
myself who deal with chronic pain at
some level every day that could be an
example of this right you know just
about every day if it's not my knees
hurting it's probably my shoulders or
it's my back or who knows what else
right and we can think of all sorts of
other sufferings that people have and
these could extend to emotions some
people are depressed some people are
anxious some people you know make stupid
decisions questions right in there so
the body is like a Locus for suffering
it's also a Locus for having Pleasures
he's not denying that but you know there
is going to be suffering involved here
and since the soul is connected with the
body here's the second reason right well
the soul shares in the suffering of the
body so you know you think for example
he doesn't go into any details here but
so you've got some chronic pain that
you're experiencing and you're thinking
oh man this is bad now what's it going
to be like 20 years from now you know uh
I could do something to reduce the pain
but everything seems to be kind of a a
trade-off if I take these pills over
here are they going to screw up my
organs we could go on and on and on this
is all matters of the Soul or the mind
and then there's a third Factor Fortune
luck literally or chance
often disappoints our hopes you know
hear the translation is just Fortune
often disappoints but what does it
actually disappoint so that the Greek
phrase runs right
um so the things that we want
um tonkat El Pita the things in
accordance with hope
so we're and you know you're not to say
don't hope or anything right that's kind
of natural to us human beings but the
world isn't going to necessarily conform
to that or if it does for a little while
watch out because 2K Fortune will
quickly change those things so happiness
is just not available just not possible
it's something that we talk about but
you know it's sort of like all these
other things gratitude friendship
beneficence if we really thought about
them we would see from the hegesian
perspective those are just you know Pipe
Dreams they're not really uh things that
we can find you could say in the wild of
human Affairs there's one last really
interesting set of differences between
um hegesius's Doctrine and many other
virtue ethics or ancient ethics right
and that is this indifference or uh it's
even like translated here as lacking
relevance right so there's a whole bunch
of things that are rattled off here and
they're all opposites and none of them
actually have to do much with pleasure
or pain and this may seem a little
counterintuitive right so what are they
well poverty and riches and you know
here we get a little bit of an argument
about that they don't actually
have anything to contribute to to
pleasure why he says well because the
rich and the poor
you know they don't actually differ when
it comes to enjoying pleasure and you
can say well wait a second rich people
can have more pleasure can't they they
can purchase all sorts of things
well right sure I mean they can enjoy
different Pleasures
the pleasure of drinking an expensive
bottle of wine is one that's you know
certainly possible for me but it's not
something I could do every day because
it would literally break the bank but if
you're a rich person you can drink fancy
wine all the time
but if you're like me here's a prime
example I I can be just as happy
drinking cheap wine because I can't tell
the difference between rich and
expensive wine uh it's nice that it's
got a decent taste and that it you know
gives you that intoxicating effect I
mean the the poor cannot enjoy
necessarily all the same Pleasures as
the rich but there's plenty of Pleasures
to actually enjoy and he goes out and he
talks about and sort of upping the game
slavery and freedom being subject to
somebody else being a free person
doesn't really make a big difference as
far as pleasure goes good or bad birth
you know the kind of family that you're
in and the opportunities and the
prestige that that affords or the
opprobrium that comes with that right or
good or bad reputation dulxa and adoxia
translated uh in in here as honor but
that's not not quite the best
translation reputation would probably be
a better way of translating it none of
these things
actually change whether we can
experience pleasure or pain according to
I guess yes we might again see this is a
little bit
paradoxical or counter-intuitive but
this is his reinterpretation of the
doctrine that this Syrian ax school has
and apparently hegesius had plenty of
his own followers who took this path
this mindset this way of looking at
things this Divergence perhaps you could
say over that of the if we want to call
them orthodox
Sierra and ax who follow aristipus's
doctrines and teachings in all of these
matters